fourth of july holiday weekend is here
and with all that fun of course comes
the concern for fires from fireworks
tree service companies tell us this is a
very busy time of year for them and
combined with dead and dry vegetation
and the dry climate it's a perfect
condition for a fire and it may seem of
course like common sense but a reminder
when shooting off fireworks stay away
from homes dry grass and trees and
always have a hose or a bucket of water
on hand to help control a small fire if
one begins
if we can recommend
four to five days of additional watering
prior to
that way
no bushes are dry they've got the most
amount of water in the can and in the
event a firework does touch a plant or a
bush or a tree a palm tree you know
hopefully it doesn't catch fires because
we have thousands hundreds of thousands
of palms in this valley and it takes
time to get them done and completed so
try to get them done early in the season
more or less like may through the end of
june so you can protect your properties
the best way to ensure your safety is to
avoid setting off fireworks at home and
instead opt for a professional show